a galera me pergunta muito esse momento
tem medo de morar sozinho não vou falar
para tinha uma demorada com a minha mãe
e pra minha mãe tudo a alma tudo dela é
alma ela é que vai dormir ela escutou um
barulho na pia no outro dia acorda ela
isso foi na cozinha ontem eu digo fui
mãe na graças à deus e quero agarrar
e beleza manhã ao chegar aqui poxa
ninguém passa estava até lavar a louça
favor mãe falar sobre medo mas uma das
poucas e tive muito medo de dentista
sentimento nativista ouvir ia morrer que
morra ponte não queria um dentista cara
daquelas laden vai dormir quando o fundo
muito nem vai
tinha medo daquele que naquelas adin do
demônio gente é essa era aquele bicho é
muito do tempo aquele negócio disse você
gravar botar no computador e rodar o
contrário se escutam música da xuxa
certeza
que negócio muito de manhã e outra coisa
você ranking dent é três semanas começou
veit ayew fez chover não tem que começar
lá quer comer o arroz não tem como
esquecer nem começou bem e tem começo
gente o próximo tem um esquema de um
dente
eu passei três semana começou violento
primeira vez eu fui no banheiro pagar a
bosch informou não kiton é muito
competente mas o que é isso
morria de medo ou porque eu morrer
sempre morria de medo é aquele
cachorrinho que lhes dá em cheque de
como é e internet é pichu não é porque o
buraco dos portos são grandes são
pequenininhas saiba comida roupas
malucas
ele vira bicho na mesma hora faz parte
do asfalto é objetiva e digo gente
porque aqueles cachorros em abuja a
atenção que eles acham ruim ele domina
casa eles que manda na casa deles e que
no meio e sofre não tem quem tira
aqueles cachorros
ele chega como visita né e aqueles
cachorros são valentim que ele pinta mas
o valente ea gente fica com medo de dar
um chute o treino aquilo
porque a gente no pi com acertar nele
que são pequenas ea gente fica com medo
disse acertar mapa
aí vai dar aquela coisa muito a família
do carro ea gente vai chegar lá patatá
falar
o cachorrinho é que a gente fica
balançando o rabo que eu tenho mais
raiva cachorro que balanço rápido que
vai 3km rosa
mas eu acho que a gente tem raiva porque
peixe não cresce
eis que 30 anos são do mesmo tamanho
acho que todo mundo a inscrição fofinho
aí vai mexer com ele e ele ficou com a
gente assim só por já vem brincar comigo
aí acho que por isso ele fica com raiva
e uma coisa que todo mundo tem aquele
cachorro é que a gente goste de ficar
medindo a distância que pode chegar
deles é a baixa adesão à itv que o
cachorro não gosta da gente a gente vê
ele rosa quando a gente chega perto a
gente fica querendo ver o limite
naquele mesmo ano
acho que vai dar mais um pouco
é aqui
e quando aquele mil se descontrola a
gente vai pegar nele assim a gente fica
com medo de dizer que o dono da casa que
a gente tá com medo um cachorro da queda
da mãe vai ficar assim estranhou não
deixa e vai pagar muito e passa a ser
boba
a gente vai jorge é o nome do cabo
a gente vai na cozinha jorge dá um pouco
de água
a gente pede água na esperança de ver
uma copa é mau é ruim vai dar o mesmo
brilho
a eth vai lavar o youtube é hora de
botar água no copo a gente fica
discutindo por zeca muita vida
a bolsa com as universidades e que pôs
preferência quando penso que não
o friagem aqui no calcanhar
mitchell eu quando pedi e jorge
ele sabe que cativam pagando a equipe
jorge
a de hoje
agora lascou
i
eu vou andar bem devagarzinho
pouca gente
chan
ele morre de medo aquele bicho
e é bem pequenininha casa uma coisa que
eu sempre tive medo é um homem-bomba que
a gente vê na noticiar nesta explode em
todo lugar e eu ficar com medo dita 5
mil reais muito no aeroporto bichos pode
pedir que o pior que eu sou amigo de um
cara e limalha mesma academia que eu
já que ele é um dom de cavalo o homem
toma muita bomba de cavar o último tanto
obrigava que eu cheguei perfil assim é
cara bondi europa
eu cheguei para ele e falei cara para de
tomar esse sonho de raquel volpato e não
pode na fazenda não estava escrito com
raiva dele e cabe nos produtos cavallo
green dam
ele entende
agora uma coisa que eu tenho muito medo
de ninguém entende porque eu falo é cama
elástica
agora fica cheio como assim como ela
acha que antes brigava vocês a cama
elástica
ela está andando assim você quando você
entra numa cama elástica você pula
eu sempre você sempre acha que vai dar
mais sempre acho que dá pra falar mais
alto fica pulando assim é bom vai
passando a cordinha é da paggo meta pela
autarquia está do lado de fora pega a
menos que você aguentar bem popular mais
a precificar a ele e mais popular com
vocês um fica tranqüila mais alto que o
outro
lá ficam na atmosfera entrou olano e só
que tem hora que o povo sabe com passa
quando sai de ocupação continua pulando
e outra cai quando o outro cai o cara
que tem pequena hannah se não quer parar
a gente fica se ela não conta para mim é
de maio por um dos pais a pessoa a
pessoa
a gente vem de câmera nos pertence
a rede
o papel existe me falou 2 e cai
estão muito bem e camila cheloni é doida
minha pauta
obrigada a cada um que me acompanha
desde o começo que tá sempre um light
segue nas redes sociais e cometas e
fofinho que tem feche e falam disso não
vai ser alguém cada lado de seu ao murro
na cara de um bando de otário valeu e
nós e se derrubarem nós nós levantar de
novo porque hoje nós é um milhão de
bicho solto